yeah essentially uh i don't read doujins
as uh i've
expressed before you don't read i don't
read i don't really
stop and preferably i do not like my
porn to be
reading we could get into that
so instead we decided the boys have both
recommended me three dojins each to read
and then we are going to end on a very
special one
where i'm sure people are going to be
excited in title we're going to talk
about
seven yeah we're going to be talking
about seven doujins or something
six dojins and a mess metamorphosis
which we'll get into um so yeah and
there's a little special thing going on
where
i don't know whose is which so i've been
recommended today you have like no clue
at all
i think i've some of them i know some of
them i know i thought i thought some
were pretty obvious
very obvious yeah damn you reading two
shots of vodka there god damn
okay some are very obvious some i don't
know
and throughout this i will be guessing
as well uh
who's who's dojin is which
recommendation
well mostly though most mostly though
this show is going to be
just watching me and god just enjoying
connor's reaction
to our recommendations i assume you both
read each other's recommendations yeah
yes it's it's funny because we
recommended three
dojinshi's each and i remember giving
the list
giving the list to joey and joey gave
his list and we were like damn we both
recommended jojo that were like 200
pages long at least
and we were just like connor it's cool
you don't need to read it all just read
like three chapters or something
until you get like the general gist of
it right yeah but then conor was like
bet i'm like first of all why do i even
read doujins i don't even know where you
go
like i was like i'm totally confused
there's lots of sites and then i look
for the sites you know and i'm
it just gets to the point where i'm just
fighting for my [ __ ] life to get the
[ __ ] on full screen
there's [ __ ] pop-ups every two
[ __ ] seconds i'm just
i'm just trying to do my homework and i
i gotta i gotta worry about
[ __ ] hot single ladies in my area
it's terrible you'll get used to it how
long did it take you to read
everything i i was under the impression
right the dojins were like
30 40 pages no a lot of them are that's
i mean yeah how did you guys manage to
find all of them that were like 200
[ __ ]
because those are the best those are the
best ones yeah and i remember you saying
uh you know just stop at one chapter
there was never any breaks in these
things so i couldn't just what do you
mean
they all had chapters not that i saw
when i was reading yeah i don't know
where i was reading them
when when it says at the end of the
chapter it says like
ending or like to be continued but i
also feel like you know
some of them literally have a whole page
that says chapter two
i did not see them but i read them all
she surprised me um so i'm gonna tell
the names of these
dojins which again still be nothing to
me dora usagi to anthony
[Music]
[Laughter]
white man butcher's japanese
anthony
what is it what is it i don't know i'm
gone what else
so you're saying the japanese name and
then the translated name is that what
this is
some of them have like english
translations of the japanese name yeah
yeah very interesting title
yeah uh kyoshi toseto okay
teacher and student yeah i mean i i i
understand that yeah
yeah yeah so i mean i just went in order
of which one you gave me so i read it
okay
okay i read doria usagi taught anthony
when should i guess who's i think it is
why did you guess it right why don't you
guess the right at the beginning
and i think because there was like a
lolly for like 10 seconds
i was
this was the cover of the main girl this
is like she
she like emanates such shinobu energy
that connor is going to immediately get
the first thing i wrote was just from
the cover i think it's joey
this is literally going to be if it's
not a milf it's a loli
the episode
yeah what were your thoughts going into
just reading hentai
because this is like our unofficial
sequel to the hentai episode i guess go
check that out if you haven't yet
it is it is exhausting reading porn
well i'm sure you read it's like if you
asked me
to like okay if you're if you're horny
you want to jack up to something you can
do it right a 10 minute video whatever
yeah if you made me sit through like a
two-hour jv when i'm not horny i
couldn't imagine
like a worse experience in my life you
know because how long were you
collectively reading these doujins for
like
three to four hours what's because back
to back well it's because we thought
right we were like i i saw the list and
i was like all of these are like
full on like books yeah i read them all
so i was like oh okay so like you know a
couple of chapters each
max takes place he just needs to get an
idea of you yeah
well there's only one of them i didn't
read fully was because there was like 20
800 500 pages right yeah i gave up on
the first one but i mean
yeah it was just it was exhausting it is
really
like i i've sat through really bad
movies that i felt were less painful
it is just difficult i like reading
dojins i
i can see it you know sometimes you you
see something like oh that's hot and
then i'm like
even if i wanted to jack off here yeah
what am i supposed to do
do i just sit there and think about what
i'm looking at like that feels like i'm
like
i'm like de-evolving like at what point
do i just do like morse code
masturbating like where i'm like oh dude
that's so hot she's telling she's gonna
[ __ ] me and morphs
like i don't know to me i like the
movement i'm not seeing enough movement
you know
i'm not seeing enough movement my eyes
are not stimulated enough
um i don't know i was i was reading this
and i just like
them every time i thought this was
really hot i'm like well what'd i do
when does it start moving
is the exact reaction i wanted yeah yeah
even if i thought it was hot
you know i just some of them you know i
will admit some of them i thought were
quite attractive i thought they were
very well done and yeah you know if they
were in anime form i'd not
it's weird because like some of these
have had anime adaptations right i know
but like to me like dojin the doujin
version
is like always hotter than the anime
version i don't know what it is about i
mean the ten times are very more intense
yeah
something i i learned very quickly i i
get like a way more intense feeling
from reading the doujins no no because
then then watching the anime adapters
to me like there's a it's a different
kind of art form right
because to me like like reading doujins
is like
like to me it's it's a really good way
to warm up right
right right because to me like who
really likes sitting through a 20-minute
hentai
you know that's i don't mind you know
i've got time you know
i mean most of the time i'm just like
whatever but for some reason in stories
and dozens i'm like
i'm listening go on yeah you're reading
yeah really so to me reading dozens is
just getting the story you know getting
getting the context and getting being
able to get the story without having to
like
just watch 20 minutes of just boring
build up and it's so much
hotter when you understand the context i
mean it is i mean
i like speed run the story most of the
time anyway like
yeah if it's like this you know you know
what they're doing it's all right yeah
yeah yeah
i've got enough understanding of the
plot that i can go now yeah right i can
do it i can enjoy so did you
like does did you like input any of the
stories of anyone yeah no i did i
actually like because obviously when
you're reading it's really hard to
not ignore the story you can't double
tap it's really really frustrating
you couldn't get you couldn't skip the
cutscenes
i feel like this is the this is the
facial floor of books you can't skip any
of the story
the cut scenes you can't just go
straight to the gameplay
as much as i tried